we've been told throughout our lives to
eat certain foods because they contain
vitamins or sometimes people might say
they also contain some minerals that you
need and so the obvious question is well
what are vitamins and what are these
minerals that folks are talking about
well the big picture idea is that
there's certain things that your body
needs and we'll talk in a second about
why your body needs these things but
also there are things that your body
needs and your body does not produce
them body
does
not
produce
there's a lot of things your body needs
that your body is capable of producing
but there's certain things it needs that
it cannot produce itself
now if these things that they need that
the body needs and it cannot produce if
they are organic
and organic is just a very fancy way of
saying if there are compounds that
involve carbons in them and most
molecules in life involve a lot of
carbons that's why they're called
organic molecules there's a whole field
of chemistry of organic chemistry which
is studying the chemistry of life for
the most part if these molecules if
these things that the body needs that it
does not produce itself organic we call
these things
vitamins
and some of the common vitamins that you
will hear people talk about are things
like vitamin a vitamin d vitamin e
vitamin k
vitamin c
and you can further divide these
vitamins
based on whether they are soluble in fat
or not so for example
vitamins a d e and k and this is by no
means an exhaustive list of vitamins
these are fat soluble
what does that mean well to be soluble
means you could be dissolved in that
thing so it can be dissolved in fat and
vitamin c
is water-soluble
now the way that the reason why this
might be relevant for you living as an
individual trying to keep your health in
good shape is that you do need all of
these vitamins and we'll talk in a
little bit about why you need them but
fat soluble vitamins they're actually
easier to overdose on because they're
soluble in fat they can stay in your
system a lot longer while water-soluble
vitamins are easier to flush out of your
system
now with that out of the way let's think
about some of these common foods you
might see and some of the vitamins that
they are known for
for example right over here you have
carrots and you might have had people
tell you hey eat carrots it's good for
your eyes and that is true but the
reason why it's good for your eyes is
that carrots contain something known as
beta carotene
and the carotene part of beta-carotene
is not a coincidence it literally comes
from latin for carrot and carotenes are
these pigment molecules it gives the
carrots this orange color right over
here and beta carotene once it's
consumed by your body it's a precursor
for vitamin
a
which is essential for your eyes and
many many other things in your body and
a precursor is just a very fancy way of
saying that
if you consume beta carotene your body
can turn it into the vitamin a that it
needs
oranges famous for vitamin c
and this isn't an exhaustive list of the
things that these foods contain but this
is some of the things that they're most
famous for and vitamin c as we talked
about is a water-soluble vitamin it's
very valuable for immune system and in a
situation where you have a severe
deficiency of vitamin c you could get a
disease known as scurvy and scurvy is
not too common anymore but several
hundred years ago sailors would often
get scurvy because they had very limited
diets they did not get fruits and
vegetables and because of that vitamin c
deficiency their collagen their
connective tissue would break down and
so it was a very horrible
and painful disease
but what if there's something your body
needs that it does not produce that is
not organic well those are the things
that we call minerals
and of course the term minerals it's
also used in a geological sense but if
we're talking in terms of biology that's
what we mean and most of the typical
minerals are really elements that you
will see on the periodic table they will
be things like phosphorus and i'm just
going to write their element symbol
phosphorus
calcium
potassium
magnesium
iron and again this is not an exhaustive
list but these are all essential for
your body as we go further in our
studies of biology you will see how
phosphorus is useful in molecules like
atp the energy store it's even in the
backbone of dna and rna we'll see how
calcium is useful not just for your
bones but even for things like muscle
contractions to send signals down
neurons you're going to need your
potassium and also sodium
magnesium also important for muscle
contraction
iron this is in your hemoglobin bonds to
the oxygen allows you to transport
oxygen in your bloodstream in red blood
cells so these are all very valuable and
a lot of these foods that we just talked
about that contain vitamins they'll also
contain minerals for example not only do
carrots contain beta-carotene they also
contain
potassium which we mentioned is
essential for things like nerve function
things like milk it has vitamins like
vitamin d but it also has minerals like
calcium which we talked about is
essential for your bones and for muscle
function
and so the big picture here is is that
vitamins and minerals are both things
that your body needs it does not produce
itself and we're going to see them over
and over again in biology so keep a
lookout for them the vitamins as we go
further in our study of biology you're
going to see them as coenzymes things
that help facilitate functions of the
cell help facilitate reactions and the
minerals you're going to see in
everything from the powerhouse of the
cell the backbone of dna you're going to
see it in muscle contraction and how
bones are formed you're going to see it
in hemoglobin you're going to see it in
nerve function